I have another thought about Ballerina Farm. Again,
I haven't been able to access the whole article,
but I have now at least seen a good chunks of,
like, the actual text.
And it doesn't escape me that this man took a woman
and molded her into the type of woman he thought he wanted.
He didn't choose a woman who wanted these things for herself.
He chose a woman who was ambitious,
who was talented, who went to Juilliard.
Do you know how hard it is to get into Juilliard?
She had these dreams of being this prima ballerina in New York City,
and she has now eight children deep on a farm with a bunch of cows.
And although she's wildly successful at this trad
wife influencing stuff,
this is not the life that she had dreamed for herself.
And now I understand that dreams change,
but this very much seems to be his dream come to life.
And he could have plugged in any woman for it.
But he chose a woman who didn't grow up wanting this.
Which just goes to show
that these men want to play king of their own castle.
And as much as he wants a queen,
he wants to keep her locked in a tower of his own making.